julie's work takes concentration and
skill
[Applause]
running her own business making beeswax
cosmetics
oh yes they're quite busy
she says she would struggle to manage it
without hormone replacement therapy so
it came as a shock when she was suddenly
unable to get her prescription
a friend of mine mentioned a few weeks
ago that she was struggling to get some
hrt gel and had to have the patch
instead but i didn't really think
anything of it
it was only when i went to our local
pharmacist here that they said oh sorry
we've run out
and i had about a days left by that
point
julie ended up taking time off work and
driving to four different villages to
get the medication
i was really starting to panic thinking
i'm going to feel rubbish if i don't get
hold of this stuff pretty soon
claire hattrick runs a menopause support
group and says the current shortage of
some hrt products has led to women
becoming so desperate they're buying
drugs on forums or meeting strangers to
trade medication
we've got a problem here and it's
spreading like wildfire and it hasn't
been going on for weeks i've known about
this for about four months now and it's
getting worse women are going and
trading in car parks saying oh well i'll
give you a pump of this if i can have
some hrt patches it shouldn't be like
that it's never good to be using other
people's medication it should be
prescribed by a clinician whether that's
a doctor a nurse or a pharmacist
and it should be properly monitored we
communicate with the pharmaceutical
companies frequently and we're being
reassured that actually
the products will be fully available in
the near future
manufacturers have blamed the supply
issues on an increase in demand and
delays in making products caused by the
pandemic while the government says
alternatives to affected products are
available and they're working with
companies to resolve the issue
certainly me just from two days of not
having it i was starting to feel unwell
but for thousands of women like julie
these are medicines they simply cannot
do without
katie barnfield sky news